we spent a couple of videos naming a
means in this video let's actually see
how they might react now to just kind of
understand what happens within a mean
let's study one in particular let's look
at ethylamine and that's its common name
and that's obviously going to be a two
carbon chain so that's the ethyl part
connected to a nitrogen so that is the a
minha part and then the nitrogen will
have two other bonds two hydrogen's just
like that and if you look at the
periodic table so here is our periodic
table right here you see nitrogen you
see nitrogen is in group five one two
three four five this says group fifteen
but we're going to ignore the transition
metals for now
so it has five valence electrons when
you look at it when you look at the
bonds here you only see one two three
valence electrons so there's going to be
two more and they're going to be in a
lone pair just like that now when you
also look at the periodic table you also
see that nitrogen is pretty
electronegative it is pretty pretty
electro electro negative in fact there's
only a few elements that are more
electronegative remember
electronegativity is just how much does
it like to hog electrons so it's more
electronegative than carbon it's to the
right of carbon and it's way more
electronegative than hydrogen so if you
compare it not only does it have this
lone pair of electrons right here but
it's also going to hog it's also going
to hog let me do it a different color
it's also going to hog these it's also
going to hog these orange electrons
these orange electrons that are on the
other side of the bond so as we know
implicitly there's a carbon right over
here there's another carbon over here
there's two hydrogen's over here we
haven't drawn all of those stuff but
it's more electronegative than
everything is spawned into so it's also
going to attract those electrons so it's
going to have a partial negative charge
it's going to have a partial negative
charge you would have a partial let me
make it very clear the partial negative
charge the partial or that's a carbon
right there the partial negative charge
is at the nitrogen itself and you're
going to have slightly partial positive
charges
the carbons and the hydrogen's
especially at the hydrogen's and now if
we just talk about the properties of it
this because it's polar this would
actually give it a reasonably high a
melting and boiling point you could
imagine a means when they are in a
solution with other amines are going to
be attracted essentially via this type
of hydrogen type bonding the negative
part of the negative a partial negative
nitrogen's are going to be attracted to
the partially positive hydrogen's of
other of other a means now the hydrogen
bonding for an amine is not going to be
as strong as it will be for say waters
or alcohols because waters and alcohols
involve oxygen and oxygen is even more
electronegative than nitrogen so these
partial charges are even stronger so
that's why hydrogen bonding is even
stronger in the case of things that have
oxygen in it like alcohol or water now
with that said let's think about how
this might react I have a lone pair over
here I also have a partial negative
charge because this guy is more
electronegative it seems like it seems
like we have a lot of negative action
going around going around the nitrogen
there and because it has that maybe it
would either like to give away electrons
or maybe take hydrogen's from other
things and that in fact is the case with
a means so in general and let me write
this down this is ethyl amine right here
just so we get our naming practice ethyl
amine this is the common name we just
said this is an ethyl group attached to
an amine but in and this is obviously a
primary amine its only attached to one
carbon right here but in the case of in
the case of an amine like this and
actually out of all of the functional
groups we will look at out of all of the
neutral functional groups we look at
because of what we just described
because it has this partial negative
charge it has this lone pair the
nitrogen is pretty electronegative this
is actually the most basic the most
basic the most and this isn't just ethyl
amine this is all a means let me write
this down a means a means are the most
basic the most
basic of the neutral of the neutral
functional groups functional groups
obviously something like a hydroxide
anion it has a negative charge it will
it will want to attract protons even
more but this one's pretty good
considering that it is neutral so given
that it's basic and we're also say and
it's a no related notion it's also
nucleophilic and just a reminder when
people talk about basicity they're
talking about how much does something
want to give away electrons or how much
does it want to take protons when you
talk about nucleophilicity or how good
of a nucleophile something is it's how
good are you at giving away electrons or
how good are you at well essentially
being attracted to protons or giving
away nutri you're going and giving away
electrons and so when you talk about
basicity you're talking about
thermodynamic property when you're
talking about nucleophilicity you're
talking about a kinetic property how
good is it at interacting the basics
tells you how stable is it once it has
interacted so given that it's a
nucleophile you could imagine I think
you see where I might be going with this
let me draw the ethyl amine again so
ethyl amine I'll draw it in a little bit
simpler so let me draw the hydrogen's
like that and then it has this lone pair
let's think about what might happen if
we have a solution of ethyl amine if we
have ethyl amine and it's mixed in it's
mixed in with some bromo ethane so
that's one two carbons right there let
me draw let me draw the bromo group and
it might not be obvious the way I drew
this bromomethane right here let me
write this down this is bromo bromo
ethane but I think it will be obvious if
I draw this carbon if I draw this carbon
right here and if I draw the other two
hydrogen's which are implicitly there so
that is one hydrogen right there and
then you have another hydrogen over here
and you have a good nucleophile in the
ethyl amine so what do you think will
happen oh yeah I also have a good
leaving group so you see I'm talking in
the language of sn2 reactions or really
just [ __ ] in the
which of nucleophilic substitution
reactions and I'm going to lean towards
the sn2 direction because I have a
primary carbon here good leaving group
pretty okay nucleophile if this was a
secondary if this especially this was a
tertiary carbon then I would be thinking
sn1 then I would say oh maybe this
leaves on its own but in an sn2 what
we're going to have is we're going to
have this this nucleophile will attack
or it'll give away its electron so it'll
give its electron to this carbon and
simultaneously since this electron is
going towards the slightly positive the
partially positive carbon here this
bromine can finally take away can
finally take away that carbons electrons
and so we just experienced an sn2
reaction this is an sn2 reaction and
then after that is done the bromine will
have left it has taken this electron so
it already had this one over here it
already had that one an actually to add
another six electrons one two three four
five six seven valence electrons for
bromine now it'll have a - one two three
four five six seven now it will have
eight it just took this one right here
it gained electrons so it has a negative
charge
and now let me draw let me draw this
part right here so we had this carbon
that carbon that hydrogen is sticking
let me draw it like this that hydrogen
is sticking out just like that the other
hydrogen is behind it the other hydrogen
is behind it it's bonded to the other
carbon up here it's bonded to another
carbon up here that's really a ch3 it
has three hydrogen's off of it
implicitly there and now we've had the
ethyl amine has has attached to it so
let me draw that so then let me draw
that so that's the nitrogen and it's
bonded to one two carbons just like that
and then it has a hydrogen a hydrogen
and then you have this electron is still
with the nitrogen and then this magenta
electron has been given to the carbon it
has been given to
the carbon just like that and since the
nitrogen has given away an electron it
now has a positive charge it has a
positive charge so when you think about
these two molecules this molecule now
has a positive charge this molecule
right now has a negative charge so they
would actually be ionically attracted to
each other and then we've actually just
formed a salt and this would be called
this would be calling this is
interesting here at least from a naming
perspective you have two ethyl groups it
might not be completely clear you have
one two carbons here and then you have
another one two carbons there we could
redraw this as or we can rewrite it as
NH two and then we have two carbons and
then another two carbons just like that
so we could call this diethyl we have
one ethyl two Ethel's
so this is diethyl let me color so this
we do a different color here so you have
an ethyl group right there an ethyl
group right there so we call this this
is a common name for it
dye ethyl and then you might want to
call it diethyl amine but it's not it's
not it's not ammonia or it's not
derivative of ammonia anymore it's a
derivative of ammonium and that's
because it's now positively charged this
nitrogen now has four bonds so this is
dye ethyl this is diethyl ammonium
ammonium diacyl ammonium is this
molecule right here and if you view it
as a salt and the salt is just a well I
don't want to go to the definition
completely of a salt but you view this
as a salt because it's ionically bonded
molecule we won one of the molecules is
diethyl ammonium the other one will be
bromide this is the bromide anion right
here and you always list the cation
first the chart positive charge one
first so this is diethyl die ethyl
ammonium bromide which we were able to
form with the sn2 reaction between ethyl
amine or ethyl amine and bromo ethane
now we can now go under another another
step here if we have a ton of this ethyl
amine floating around
if we have an excess and early on we
will have a lot more of that then we
will have of this thing right here if we
have a ton of ethylamine floating around
let me draw some ethylamine if we have a
ton of the ethylamine floating around it
might be able to grab one of the
hydrogen's from the diethyl ammonium
over here so you could imagine a
situation where it grabs a hydrogen
essentially gives its electron to the
hydrogen and then that hydrogen's
electron that hydrogens electron can be
taken back can be taken back by the
nitrogen and I'll draw this as an
equilibrium because it's not really that
much more likely that this guy takes
away that guy's electron then that guy
can take or go and then take the
electron back so it's a reversible
reaction but if that were to happen then
this guy this guy right over here will
then look like this you have the ethyl
group bonded to a nitrogen that only has
one hydrogen on it let me just draw it
like this a nitrogen that only has one
hydrogen on it and then he's bonded to
another ethyl group to another ethyl
group right over there and now he has
his so if you viewed this as an electron
right there he has his lone pair so he
took that that looks like yellow ocher
but now it's kind of a yellow-green
color took that back from the hydrogen
and is now neutral got an electron back
so now this is just diethyl ammonia this
is just diethyl ammonia this is dye dye
ethyl diethyl ammonia actually know it
sorry it wouldn't be died at the Lamoni
it would be diethyl amine sorry about
that let me let me let me erase that
this would be diethyl amine diethyl
amine it would be ammonia ammonia is
just NH NH let me draw it like this
ammonia just to make things clear is
this and that's why my brain was telling
us go ammonia and then ammonium is this
ammonium ammonium is
this give away one of these electrons to
a hydrogen proton you have a positive
charge now when you do the common naming
when you have when it's kind of ammonium
derivative you do say diethyl ammonium
and then my brain said okay now that we
got rid of the hydrogen I went back to
ammonia so I said diethyl ammonia but
that's wrong obviously this is now an
amine so we use the common naming for a
means and we get back to dye ethyl amine
and then this guy over here will turn
into ammonium or sorry this guy over
here will turn into ethyl ammonium sorry
for all the confusion so this guy over
here is the nitrogen two hydrogen's
ethyl group and then he grabbed another
hydrogen so he grabbed this hydrogen
over here grabbed that hydrogen over
here so now he has a positive charge
since he give since he gave away that
electron over there so now he is ethyl
ethyl ammonium emoni
ethyl ammonium but this is reversible
right here but you can see through this
sn2 reaction we were able to essentially
get rid of one of these hydrogen's and
substitute it with another ethyl group
we went from having a primary amine
right this is bonded to one carbon to
having a secondary amine through this
sn2 reaction it's bonded to two carbons